the things I like about fasting is  talked about a way to artificially wake  yourself up you know day five to day  seven of a fast you are going to be very  awake you know admittedly you might be  focused on food right so but all your  senses are optimally working you can  smell things very far away you can hear  things very far away assuming that you  can control your urges for food you know  that's about one of the most awake  states that you can be in as a human  being  unfortunately you know if you're eating  lots of food lots of processed food  you're not sleeping well you're  basically not challenging your mind and  you're not exercising that's the inverse  state of fasting and you're basically